رغم تعاهدات المتكرره لكير برلين وواشنطن
تتراجعان عن تزويده اوكرانيا في الدبابات
الحديثه
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد للعربيه تماسكها
بحل الدولتين في القضيه الفلسطينيه وتعتبر
ان تطبيقه يحتاج وقتا طويل
بقيمه 20 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في الاشرطه اللي اهم الانباء من
العربيه
قبل ايام اعلنت المانيا
اذا وافقت عليها برلين مسؤولون امريكيون
في البنتاجون اداره
ابراج
تحتوي تكنولوجيا معقده جدا
بالمعارك في الحرب العالميه الاولى الا ان
ذلك لم يقنع اداره
في قاعده الجويه في المانيا يوم الجمعه
المقبل لدراسه تقديم المزيد من الاسلحه
الاوكرانيا
وزير الدفاع الالمانيه الجديد بوريس
بيستوريوس قال اين قرار تقديم المزيد من
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا سيكون البند الاول على
جدول الاعمال
القومي المخابرات الامريكيه تقدر انه توجد
وتوترات متزايده بين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
من خلال الانتصارات في ساحه المعركه
في الحرب
المقابل ده رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي خلال مشاركته في فعاليات
الاجتماع السنوي للمنتدى الاقتصاديه
العالميه
دول العالم الى تسريع اتخاذ القرارات
الحاسبه لوقف الحرب
[موسيقى]
2014 السلام
انتقدت الامم المتحده تقصير في تنفيذ
الاتفاق الذي يسمح بتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود لكنها لم
تتطرق الى تراكم اكثر من 100 سفينه في
المياه التركيه في انتظار الموافقه على
الابحار وعمليات التفتيش
وبموجب الاتفاق الذي توصلت اليه روسيا
واوكرانيا وتركيا والامم المتحده في يوليو
الماضي يجري تفتيش السفن المتجهه الى
اوكرانيا والقادمه منها في المياه
بعد تحطم المروحيه التي كانت توقل وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني وعددا من كبار
المسؤولين لا يزال وتحقيقه جاريه لمعرفه
السيناريو المحتمل الذي تسبب بسقوط
مهمه العسكريه الروتينيه انتهت بخساره
اوكرانيا الثلاثه من ابرز مسؤوليها وهم في
طريقهم لبقعه ساخنه من القتال
مدينه بروفاريه الاوكرانيه اصبحت شاهده
على اللحظات الاخيره
دوله في وزاره الشؤون الداخليه
لجهاز الدوله حادثه الواقعه بالقرب من
العاصمه كيف في مدينه بروفاريه على بعد 20
كيلو مترن شمال شرق العاصمه تسببت الحادثه
في سقوط 10 القتل والمصابين بينهم اطفال
متاثرين باسطدام المروحيه بمبدا سكني
وحضاره رسمي السلطات الاوكرانيه تعمل على
معرفه ملابسات الحادثه وتجمع الادله فيما
اعلنت المانيا استعدادها للمشاركه في
التحقيق
الوقوف على ما اذا كان الحادث مدبرا لانه
بسبب عطل فني او بسبب الطقس
الجزيره بالذكر ان عمليه نقل المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين تتم اعاده بطائره مروحيه تحلق
على مستوى منخفض جدا ما قد ينطوي على
مخاطر عده وفاه وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
التي تاتي وسط تصعد الحرب بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا قد تؤثر على عمل الحكومه مع
خسارتها وزير المختصه في مهام حيويه بينها
اداره الشرطه خلال الحرب
ديسباسيتو
صباح على صوت صفير في البدايه كان هناك
صوت صفير ولكن لم يكن هناك انذار بغاره
جويه نظرت الى هاتفي ولم يكن هناك اي
تنبيه وبعد ذلك في غضون ثواني نظرت الى
النافذه ورايت ضوء احمر متوهجا يسقط فوق
الحضانه اعتقدته البدايه انه صاروخ لان كل
شيء وكانت هناك شضايا تتساقط في كل مكان
نظرت عبر النافذه مره اخرى ورايت وجثثه
ملقاه وشدايا
هكذا متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
برايز في تصريحات للعربيه ان الولايات
المتحده 9 للمساعده في تهدئه التوترات
والتشجيع الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين عن
الامتناع عن التصعيد مضيفا حاله الدولتين
هو هدفه واشنطن لكنه تحقيقه لن يكون قريبا
التوترات ولتشجيع الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين على الامتناع عن التصعيد لا
يزال نهجون على المدى الطويل يتمثل في دعم
حل الدولتين ونامل في نهايه المطاف ان
يعيش الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيون جنبا الى
جنب ويتمتعون بمقاييس متساويه من
الاستقرار نحن
بعيد لا احد يتحدث في الوقت الحالي عن
امكانيه في حوار بناء على المدى القريب
يتوج بحل الدولتين بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
يواجه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي قرار
المحكمه العليا دراماتيكيه بشطب تعيين
رئيس حزب شرسه الدينيه واحد اهم اركان
حكومته ارياه في الحكومه بسبب ازالته
السابقه بقضيه فساد ضربه قويه لائتلاف
نتنياهو الحكومي من المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه التي قررت باغلبيه 10 قضاه في
مقابل معارضه واحد الغاء تعيين رئيس حزب
سياسه درعي وزيرا في الحكومه بسبب ادانته
في قضيه فساد ما يعني ان على نتنياهو ان
يقيله من منصبه وما يعني ايضا بان الحرب
على النظام القضائي التي تسميها الحكومه
اصلاحاته ستستعر ازواج دستوريه وربما
ازمايتيه ولكن مما لا شك فيه هناك ازمه
بين السلطه القضائيه والسلطه التنفيذيه هي
الحكومه في سبب اقاله الوزير ايه ايه رايك
اللافته ان قرار المحكمه العليا جاء رغم
قيام وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بعرض خطه
اضعاف القضاء عشيه المداولات في ملف درعي
مع تبر تحديدا للنظام القضائي الاسرائيلي
الذي يحاكم نتنياهو في ثلاث قضايا فساد
المح كمه يتجاوزت كل الحدود بالتدخل في
قانون اساسي اقر باغلبيه 63 شخصا عكس
الرغبه الاغلبيه للاسف المحكمه العليا
تعتقد بانها حاكم خفي لاسرائيل
اذا لم اقاله درع فان حكومه اسرائيل تخالف
القانون وحكومه لا تلتزم بالقانون هي
حكومه غير قانونيه
الائتلاف سيسرع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء بهدف محاوله اعاده درع الى منصبه
ومن بينها تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه للسياسيين من
الاحتلال في لجنه تعيين القضاء والغاء
فقره المعقوليه القضائيه كالتي حسمت امر
درعي باعتبار انه غير معقول ان يبقى وزيرا
بعد ادانته المتكرره بقضايا فساد الملك
المعركه بين التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
ونظام القضائيه شهدت نقله نوعيه بالغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه توزير درعي
تصب الزيت على نار المواجهه الدائره في
البرلمان وفي الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
المتحده على بيع طائرات اف 16 لتركيا
بقيمه 20 مليار دولار
عن دعمها
تجاه سوريا
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
ازمه ماليه تعصف بتويتر عن دفع الايجار
الايراني
على قوائم العقوبات وادراج الحرس الثوري
قالت منظمه العفو الدوليه ان سلطات
الايرانيه حرمت الناشطه الكرديه الهام
مدرسي من الرعايه الصحيه اللازمه بعد
احتجازها تعسفيا بما يشكل تهديدا على
حياتها وذكرت المنظمه انه جرى نقلب مدرسي
من السجن الى المستشفى امس بعد سبيع من
حرمالها من رعايه الصحيه المتخصصه عمدا
وهو مقد تواجه بسببه خطر الاصابه بالكشل
الكبدي والموت وضعت العفو الدوليه
اثار التصريحات ورئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شعيب سوداني غضب ايران بعد تكراره في
عده مناسبات عباره الخليج العربي وتاكيدها
على التقارب مع محيط العراق العربي ما فتح
تساؤل حول مغزى مثل تلك التصريحات واسباب
الهجوم الايراني اليوم نحن جزء من
المنظومه العربيه ونحن حريصون على
استمراريه
مع دول الخليج العربي
محمد الشيعه السوداني فتحت عليه نيران
الجاره ايران فبات بعدها متصدرا لعناوين
صحفيا من الالقاب المسيئه للسوداني
تاره بانكشاف ما كان يخفيه من نوايا وتاره
اخرى بالتخطيط لاستداره العراقيه مفاجاه
بوجه طهران
بل ان البعض ذهب ابعد من ذلك بطرح تساؤل
حول ما اذا كانت مواقف سوداني تمثل تحديدا
لايران ايران يبدو انها ضاقت ذرعا
بتصريحات السوداني المتتابعه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه خاصه وانها لم تفق بعد
من ترده عباره الخليج العربي خلال افتتاح
بطوله كاس الخليج العربي الخامسه والعشرين
فضلا عن تايده لبقاء القوات الاجنبيه وفي
القلب منها الامريكيه لاستكمال مهمه تحريش
هجوم الصحف الايرانيه اتى بعد ايام من
استدعاء طهران السفير العراقي لديها
للاحتجاج
لكن السؤال الاكبر الان لدى البعض هل تمثل
تصريحات السوداني تحولا سياسيا حقيقيا ام
انها تمت بتفهم داخل كتله الاطار التنسيقي
التي ايدت توليه المسؤوليه والتي يدين
اغلبها بالولاء لايران
من شركه توتال الاساسيه في سان فرانسيسكو
للبيع
ثلاثا مكتبيه هذا المزاد اثار سخريه البعض
بعد ان تسببت اداره ذلك الجديد الى الماسك
بانكسات مستمره للطائره
كرسي وقالت القهوه طويله ومعدلات مطبخيه
ليست اثاث بيت يريد اصحابه الهجره بل هي
مقتضيات اكبر الشركات التكنولوجيه في
العالم الطاقه الحرب تويتر
تغييرات التي اجراها الملك الجديد
دولار تعرض 631 قطعه من مبداها في
كاليفورنيا على الموقع
اله القهوه
البسيط الذي قد يمر به الموظفون يوميا وهم
غير بوجود
الف دولار
مبالغ لم تحل ازمه تويتر الماليه الا انها
على مبدا القليل قد يسند الحال
[موسيقى]
ما تسبب برفع الدعوه والقضائيه عليه في
الوقت الذي يحاول فيه مالك الطائر الازرق
يخفض النفقات بشكل كبير
ويزيد الدخل باي وسيله
مصيبه
عمرها خمس سنوات تحلقت في الفضاء الرقمي ب
140 حرفا كلفت الملياردير الامريكيه 20
مليون دولار تبعته عشرون اللي هو الاخرى
دفعت شركه سيارات الكهربائيه المبلوكه
تسلم
الى شركه خاصه يبلغ سعر بها
220$ ثم ختمها بانهمه الى مضمون لكن القصه
لن تجري كما توقع ماسك ففي البدايه ارتفعت
اسهم تسلم بنسبه 11% مع اللحظات الاولى من
التغريده لكنها لم تصل ابدا الى المستوى
الذي وعد به والبالغ 420 دولار
بلغت اعلى مستوى لها في ذلك اليوم عند
387 دولار
حضرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه من الوصول
الى سقف الاقتراضي الحالي يوم الخميس ومن
دون زياده سقف الدين العام بحلول يونيو
المقبل لن يكون لدى الولايات المتحده
الاموال الكافيه لدفع فواتيره
[تصفيق]
بين الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي في مجلس
النواب الامريكي معركه رفع سقف الدين
العام تاخذ الطبعا مختلفا هذا العام
سياسيا واقتصاديا
61 مره في السنوات الماضيه ويدعي
الديمقراطيون انها مساله روتينيه فقط لا
غير الان حول ما اذا كان رفع سقف الدين
العام ضروريا للحفاظ على استمرار الاقتصاد
ولا اعتقد ان المساله ستطول كثيرا بين
الطرفين لان التاثيرات ستطالب كل الاسواق
العالميه وليس فقط السوق الامريكي
الجمهوريون المحافظون يطالبون بفرض
تخفيضات في الميزانيه من اجل الموافقه على
رفع سقف الدين العام ويصلون على انهم لا
يريدون ان تتخلف الدوله عن السداد في حين
يرفض الديمقراطيون اي اجراء فيما يتعلق
بالديون خاصه في ظل الصفقه بين مكارثي
والجمهوريين المحافظين والتي افضت الى
تراسه للمجلس والتي يسرون على الكشف عن
تفاصيلها
ستصلوا الولايات المتحده الى الحد الاقصى
للديون الفيدراليه الاجماليه التي تبلغ
واحدا 31,000,000 و400 مليار دولار يوم
الخميس
وزاره الخزانه الى تدبيره خاصه يمكن في ظل
اتجاه الارادات الحالي ان تؤخر التخلف عن
السداد حتى الربيع
مماثل لما حصل عام 2001 10 من المحتمل ان
تقوم لاداره الامريكيه ببعض التحفيظات في
بعض المجلات الوا لا الامر الذي يمكن ان
يسمح المجلس النواب ان يقول انه انتصر في
المعركه ولكن من غير المحتمل المشهد اي
اجراء كبير
وتسبب في التخلف عن السداد فان نطاق
العواقب يشمل انهيار سوق الاوراق الماليه
والركود ومعدلات فائده اعلى للمستهلكين
وضعف الضلعر وخفض التصنيف الائتمان
للولايات المتحده وحكومه غير قادره على
الوفاء بجميع التزاماتها من تمويل الجيش
لتقديم خدمات الضمان الاجتماعيه
استحقاق كبير في انتظار الكونجرس في
الساعات وحتى الايام المقبله فاما غرق
البلاد في ركود عميق وما التحرك بسرعه
لتمرير تشريع يعالج حدود الدين حتى لا
يكون هناك فرصه المخاطره بتخلف كارثي
لسداده ديون ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
السابق
مع عوده حسابه على تويتر حيث تقدمت حمله
ترامب الرسميه الى فيسبوك
قبل عامين وذكرت حمله ترامب في رسالتها
الى متى
الخطاب العام بشكل كبير
على ترتيب افكار جديده لتغريدته الاولى
هذا الهدوء الى منطقه القصر بنقشير قرب
بطاريه طرابلس الدولي بعد وقوع اشتباكات
بين مجموعات المسلحه بجروحين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
استئناف في المشاورات المتعلقه بالمسار
الدستوري بين البرلمان والمجلس الاعلى
للدوله رئيس البرلمان
لقاء القاهره الذي عقد هذا الشهر بصيغه
نهائي
او بحثت امين محمد نائبه الامير العامري
عمر المتحده مع وزير الخارجيه الافغاني
بالوكاله حقوق النساء
عمل معظم موظفات منظمات الاغاثه ومنعت
النساء والفتيات من الذهاب الى المدارس
على ضروره الحفاظ على حقوق الانسان خاصه
بنسبه للنساء والفتيات وشجعت الاعفاء من
الحظر المفروض على العاملات في مجاله
اعلنت رئيسه وزران نيوزيلندا جاستين
دائردين انها ستستقيل من مصيبها الشهر
المقبل وقالت امام اعضاء من حزب العمال
الذي تنتمي له حان الوقت بالنسبه
عام 2017 قبل ان تقود حزبها الى فوز ساحق
في الانتخابات التي اجريت بعد ذلك بثلاث
سنوات ابهرت استطلاعات رؤيه الاخيره تراجع
شعبيهتها وشعبيه ايضا
والله الى وقفتنا الرياضيه
في كاس السوبر الايطاليه التي اقيمت في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بعد تغلب على
ميلان بثلاثيه نظيفه
في دور 16 في مسابقه كاس ملك اسبانيا
يلتقي برشلونه مع مضيفه في فريق سبته
ونجح فالنسيا بحاجه بطاقه التاهل الى ربع
نهائي مسابقه كاس ملك اسبانيا
تقام اليوم مبارتين في الجوله الرابعه عشر
للدوري السعودي لكره القدم يحل العداله
ضيفا على الباطن ويستقبل الاتحاد ضيفه
والفيحاء في جده
تشهدوا مدينه البصره اليوم المباراه
النهائيه لبطوله كاس الخليج لكره القدم
والتي تجمع المنتخب العراقي مع نظيره
العماني
واياكم الى نهايه
رغبه تعاهدات المتكرره لكيف برلين وواشنطن
تتراجعان عن تجويدي اوكرانيا بالدبابات
الحديثه
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد للعربيه تمسكها
بحل الدولتين في قضيه الفلسطينيه واعتبرون
انقر تتوقع بوابه
اف 16 المقاتله لقيبه 20 مليار دولار
البسيط بعد قليل على شاشه العربيه شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]